don't be serious about this because you
had the guard three thousand no no no no
this is actually a serious point right
this is a very serious point because the
Western world has collapsed in real time
and it's a failed society and one of the
reasons it's a failed Society is because
of the over sexualization especially
females as a whole if a woman comes up
to me and goes I'll be the best sex you
ever had I am [ __ ] revolted I don't
want the best sex I've ever had I want
you to be pure and a virgin you should
know what sex is cook my [ __ ] dinner
shut up don't come and talk to me about
[ __ ] sucking dick it's vile it's
disgusting I don't want to hear that
[ __ ] can I say something I don't want to
hear that [ __ ] what I want is a woman
that makes me look good no woman who's
running around talking about sucking
dick can make me look good so I lose
interest completely and utterly and
that's the truth so what she's saying is
completely correct these are old school
things but it's not about the ACT yes
you can order food of course it's about
the status that comes with it that's
what it's about uh Sagittarius spoken
like a true one that is true